يمكن الموافقة على التطعيمات للأطفال من سن 5 إلى 11
عامًا في غضون أيام قليلة فقط
لدى الآباء الكثير من الأسئلة
حول هذا الأمر ، إليك سؤالًا كبيرًا ، الجرعة
جيدة ، سيحصل هؤلاء الأطفال الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 5 و 11 عامًا على
جرعة أصغر من الأطفال الذين تبلغ أعمارهم 12 عامًا أو
أكبر  على الرغم من أنهم قريبون من
العمر ويمكن أن يكون لديهم آه ، فأنت تعرف أحجام أجسام أكبر بكثير ،
ما الذي تقوله للآباء لأنك
تعلم أنهم قلقون
بشأن هذا
الأمر ، لا في الواقع أنا لا أفعل ذلك لأنك
ستضطر إلى إجراء عملية قطع  في مرحلة ما
وتم إجراء القطع التجريبي في ذلك
العمر من 5 إلى 11. كما تعلم
من سن 12 عامًا فما فوق ، كانت الجرعة هي
الجرعة القياسية ، قاموا بتخفيض الجرعة الآن
إلى حوالي ثلث ما كانت
عليه الآن 30 ميكروغرامًا.  10 ميكروغرام ، لذلك
أعتقد أن هذا أمر منطقي إذا
كنت ستضطر إلى البدء في
قياسه حسب وزن الجسم وأشياء من
هذا القبيل ستصبح حقًا مربكة للغاية ،
فأنا لست مهتمًا حقًا
كطبيب وكطبيب  علم المناعة
يعرف أنواع الأشياء  عندما
تحفز جهاز المناعة ، أعتقد أنه
سيكون على ما يرام ، أعتقد أن هذا كان اختيارًا حكيمًا ،
نعم كان هذا هو سؤالي التالي ،
ماذا عن كتلة الجسم أو الحجم أو الارتفاع
وكل ذلك ولا تجد ذلك
ضروريًا ،
لا أعتقد ذلك  لذا لا أعتقد حقًا
أنه سيكون محيرًا للغاية إذا
كان هذا هو الحال ، أعتقد أن هذه
طريقة جيدة لقطع هذا الأمر جيدًا ، لذا
استمع إلى استطلاع حديث لمؤسسة عائلة كايزر
يُظهر هذا أن حوالي
ثلث الآباء فقط  من خمسة إلى
أحد عشر عامًا من سن خمسة إلى أحد عشر عامًا سيقومون بتلقيح
أطفالهم بمجرد أن يصبح متاحًا
مع تجويف يتجه لأسفل في الوقت الحالي في
حالات غالبًا ما تكون أقل حدة عند الأطفال
يسأل الكثير من الآباء عما إذا كان أطفالهم في
حاجة إليها حقًا ، فماذا تقول لهم
؟  أعلم أعتقد أنني أعتقد أن الإجابة على
ذلك لأنني أشعر باليقين إلى حد ما أن
الإجابة على ذلك ستكون فكرة جيدة
أن تقوم بتطعيم الأطفال الذين
تعرفهم عندما تسأل الناس عن
احتمالية حصولهم على
التطعيمات المتاحة لهم.  عندما يكونون بالغين
أو من أجل أطفالهم ، فأنت تعلم أننا
نبدأ في حوالي 35 و 37 عامًا
ثم عندما يبدأ الناس في رؤية
أن التطعيمات يتم توزيعها
ويتم إعطاؤها وأن
الأمور تسير على ما يرام ،
يكتسب الناس المزيد من الثقة ، لذلك أعتقد
ذلك  سيزداد عدد الأشخاص الذين سيكونون
مستعدين إن لم يكونوا متحمسين
لتطعيم أطفالهم
كما تعلمون ، لا أشعر
أنه من المهم تطعيم الأطفال بلا
شك من وجهة نظر إحصائية عندما
يصاب الأطفال بالعدوى ،
فمن المرجح جدًا أنهم لن يفعلوا ذلك  لديك
نتيجة خطيرة مقارنة بشخص مسن
مثلي أو شخص لديه
حالة مرضية كامنة ولكن هذا لا
يعني أن الأطفال معفيون من بعض
الأمراض الخطيرة لأن كل ما عليك
فعله
هو الذهاب إلى مستشفيات الأطفال في جميع
أنحاء البلاد وأنت  انظر بشكل خاص
إلى متغير دلتا الذي لديه
فرصة أكبر بكثير لنقل
إصابة المزيد من الأطفال بالعدوى ومع زيادة عدد
الأطفال  قد يصاب البعض منهم ربما
يكون لنسبة صغيرة
نتيجة خطيرة كما تريد
التأكد من
أنه ليس لدينا موقف يكون فيه
الأطفال
عن غير قصد وبراءة عندما
يصابون بالعديد منهم دون أي
أعراض ينشرها داخل
وحدة الأسرة وهو أمر
تشير الدراسات الحديثة إلى أنه قد
يكون هذا هو الحال ، لذلك هناك سبب وجيه حقًا
لتطعيم
الأطفال وهذا هو السبب الذي يجعلنا
نأمل أن نتمكن من الإجابة على
الأسئلة المعقولة التي لن يكون لدى الوالدين
شك في أن لديهم
أسئلة جيدة ونأمل أن نتمكن خلال التوعية
من الإجابة بشكل مناسب على
أسئلة أولياء الأمور